[Music]
[Applause]
always appreciate Mike Tannenbaum
joining us he makes a smarter ESPN NFL
front office Insider former general
manager in the NFL and uh you can see
him on get up also on SportsCenter the
different shows that he contributes to
and joins us now Mike the chiefs of
dynasty
not yet Dan but boy they're quickly
going to that conversation and what's
remarkable is they had a 154 games
played by rookies this year the third
most of any Super Bowl champion wow so
one more Super Bowl Super Bowl
appearance AFC title game like what
constitutes a dynasty in the NFL
yeah one more title because now you're
going to be sort of like into that next
Echelon of like the Belichick and Breeze
are still a little bit of ways away but
above anybody else you know anybody that
you think about in terms of like sort of
like one and done like the mcvays of the
world certainly the Kyle Shanahan's like
those other really good teams this kind
of puts you between Belichick Brady and
the rest of The Fray explain to me from
a front office perspective why Eric the
enemy would feel the need to leave the
Chiefs as the offensive coordinator to
go to the commanders to be the offensive
coordinator you know Dan that's what the
marketplace is saying right now like
unfortunately for Coach the enemy he's
just not getting the credit as the
offensive coordinator of the Chiefs
where they've had remarkable success and
we're seeing much lesser guys thinking
nothing away from the Shane steikens of
the world that have been a coordinator
for 10 minutes where Eric the enemy held
literally
identify Patrick Mahomes helped draft
them develop them and he can't get a
head coaching job if I'm him I'm
probably doing the same thing I'm going
someplace else I'm cutting the umbilical
cord I love Andy Reid but I got to go on
my own so I can get to the next step but
do you think it's because Reed and you
know Mahomes Loom so large that he'll
never get the credit he deserves or once
therefore if I go to the commanders and
I you know create something around Sam
Howell and and those young offensive
weapons now I got a better chance of
being a head coach
yeah I mean unfortunately that's the
case that's what the marketplace has
clearly told us that I have to take a
half a step forward to take two step
half a step back okay two steps forward
it's unfortunate Dan I spent time coach
the enemy he is smart he's relatable
um there's a reason players love playing
for him but the marketplace has
basically told him like we think Andy
Reid deserves a credit not you and to
his credit looks like he's gonna go off
on his own and and you know carve his
own path I heard you say this on the
mothership and I wanted to have you on
so you could relay it to my audience
about what you would do if you're
running the Jets and Aaron Rodgers is a
possibility there that you got to entice
him to give me at least two years and
your thought process if you were the GM
would be what
I'll reluctantly give up the first round
pick to Green Bay I'm going to pay Aaron
he has this roughly 60 million dollar
option bonus so I'm gonna pay you 60
million a year but Aaron we need to know
you're gonna be here for two years so
fully guaranteed 30 in year one 90 and
2024. and now I know you're here for two
years buddy
but if I said you could have Derek Carr
for less money for a longer period of
time or you could have Aaron Rodgers
I'll go with Rogers you know when you
really look at Derek Carr he's been a B
minus Dan like when you look at
objectively 32 years old he's been in
one playoff game and now that we have
seven teams make the playoffs in each
conference I want a little bit more
juice for my quarterback look A-Rod
didn't play well last year we know that
lost to Detroit didn't make the playoffs
he's an all-time great I'm gonna try to
squeeze two productive years out of him
yeah I just don't want drama any more
drama that comes with the position now
Aaron are you gonna play I know you're
financially incentivizing him
but I I would almost feel it because it
feels like the Jets are Maybe
two years away from being a playoff team
maybe maybe next year but in four if I
look at four years then I think they're
going to be a playoff team and and you
know forced to be reckoned with I just
don't know are they
are they on schedule or ahead of
schedule as far as being a playoff team
in your opinion
with Aaron Rodgers I think they're a
playoff team and if you and I were
running just I'd say a couple things one
let's go get A-Rod and draft his
replacement like we could do both those
things and I think if we had Derek Carr
and we're competing with Josh Allen and
Patrick Mahomes and Joe burrow and
Justin Herbert and Lamar Jackson
I just think we're going to be at the
end of the day feel like we're coming up
a little bit short so when you think
about how do we win the division and
again we don't know what's going to
happen with Tua and his health and
um but clearly Miami's added a lot of
Firepower there I I need to score points
and I know I can do that with Rogers
okay would you rather have Lamar Jackson
or would you rather have Aaron Rodgers
with the Jets yeah if I could get Rogers
for two years absolutely if I only get
Rogers for one I'm going out to Lamar
Jackson Danny he's only 26 years old
remarkably he's already thrown for 124
touchdown passes he's rushed for over uh
20 more as well and this guy has won an
MVP every defensive coordinator you
talked to in the league job one is to
stop Lamar I know durability is a little
bit of issue but you know what it's an
issue for Matt Stafford and Dak Prescott
we've seen 68 quarterbacks start a game
this year so to me Lamar Jackson because
of his age that's who I'm going after
next are you convinced Tom Brady is
retired retired
you know that's a simple question a
complicated answer
Dan if Josh calls him up in June and
says hey buddy I need 17 freaking games
you're not even allowed like it's what
we did with farb like Brett I'm gonna
find your ass if you don't hunt and fish
every Tuesday like here is the farm
here's and I'd run the same play with
Tom like Tom you're not allowing the
building till Wednesday I need you for
basically 50 practices 17 games gronk's
gonna come in to be your caddy let's go
okay if you're Josh McDaniels Tom Brady
for a year
Jimmy Garoppolo for four years
yeah well I think Tom you know it's like
the mathematical equation one more Good
Year probably equals five more years for
Josh in terms of hey you know can we
develop Stidham is it another draft
choice you know with Jimmy G again like
Dan if we're running a team in the AFC
like our calculus has to be like do we
have the Firepower again it's murderer's
row right now and they're young Mahomes
Herbert who's beating Mahomes Borough
who's been to a Super Bowl Lamar's been
an MVP Josh Allen's been to an AFC
Championship game like those five or six
teams like the bar is high and I just
don't know if we want to go into a fight
for 17 games with Jimmy G against that
batting lineup any hesitancy in giving
Jalen hurts the market value
no and I would say this here's what's
really interesting then on that one it's
50 million a year and if I'm look
there's scar tissue in that building
with Carson once I get it but if I'm the
Eagles I'm going to go as long as
possible Josh Allen did six my home's to
ten and here's the interesting thing
he's a second round pick Dan if I'm
Jalen hurts I may say you know what
fellas I'm not coming in without another
you know a new deal and they have that's
the leverage that Jalen hurts he has a
lot of Leverage about not showing up but
you think it's going to be 50.
I don't see how it could be anything
less when you look at the market and
where it is right now I think 50 is the
minimum and if I'm the Eagles I'm going
first because borough is eligible yeah
we're in eligible Herbert's eligible
yeah
do you think they're going to get more
like borough is going to get more than
Jalen hurts
yeah absolutely and you know Chris candy
made this comment like look we're all
talking about it when you look at the
macro economics of the NFL Dam and you
look at the Amazon deal and now the
YouTube deal that's going to kick in for
Sunday Ticket caps 228 this year like
we're looking at 250 275 and we're going
to look back and be like oh you know
what like Joe burrow at 52 and a half
that's not bad and the world's changing
before between before our eyes the
world's changing and I am trying to get
my guy signed ASAP and then let
everybody else Blow by it okay so you
want to be the first guy to sign
therefore but but I don't know if
everybody's looking at what happened in
Cleveland with DeSean Watson
and saying I want my my client to get
guarantee everything's guaranteed so we
start at 230 million guaranteed is is
that what's happening now with the NFL
yeah absolutely and it'll be interesting
Dan Kennedy will somebody else blank you
know for me I think there's another team
that we give Lamar the guarantee before
he'd be the Ravens if the Ravens were
gonna do that they would have gone
through all the angst and done it a year
ago so clearly they're not doing that my
question is like does the Atlanta
Falcons does the New York Jets say you
know what like we think it's 170 we're
going to do 230 and we're gonna bite the
bullet on the next whatever the number
is 50 60 million to get this thing done
I think there's a team that could do it
this year because again when you look at
the league Dan I have 14 teams that need
a quarterback including the entire NFC
South yeah and in the draft there's
maybe three guys in will Levis Bryce
young and CJ Stroud so it's certainly
going to be a quarterback driven market
and someone may bite the bullet and do
it I would love to see Lamar Jackson in
Atlanta on the turf and they've got some
weapons there I think because I thought
Atlanta was going to be on the cusp of
being a playoff team now granted the NFC
South had felt like everybody was going
to be on the cusp being in the playoffs
or out of the playoffs uh I'll leave you
with this the Bears are on the clock if
you're running the Bears
depending on what your grade is with
Bryce young and what you could get for
Justin Fields what do you do at the top
of the draft
this is easy for me it's Bryce young Dan
I've scouted him I've talked to him I've
met with him this he has a chance to be
really really special he's small and
that's a concern I would trade Justin
Fields who's a good quarterback but we
just went through talking about all
these 50 million dollar plus deals if
you can reset that clock for four years
and get brace on a deal go use that cap
space get a one for Justin Fields I
think you're being much better off in
three years yeah I'm right there with
you because people say oh you know
Justin Fields hasn't had a good
offensive line he hasn't had good
weapons I get that but I also have to
worry about you know is this sustainable
that he can continue to run like this
he's wonderful but uh if I can get Bryce
young in there reset the clock and then
maybe start to spread that wealth around
then I it feels like I got a better
chance of winning in Chicago
I totally agree and you can look at
Jacksonville to me they took advantage
of Charles Lawrence's deal and they went
out and got a whole bunch of bees you
know Christian Kirk and Evan Ingram
um
I just feel like there's a way you could
rebuild that team much quicker you know
they added a couple guys on defense and
Brandon Sheriff turned out to be a
really good offensive lineman that I
think really helped Trevor Lawrence and
I would do the same like guys like
Andrew Wiley and Orlando Brown are free
agents you've got to help the
quarterback Dan and I
take Bryce young reset that clock spend
the cap money on the lines and go from
there always great to talk to you have a
great weekend Mike thank you yeah really
appreciate having me Dan have a good
week off Mike Tannenbaum ESPN NFL front
office Insider former NFL executive